Привет! В прошлый раз мы зафиксировали, где промпт фразы перестает работать. Это серии,
воспроизводимость, командная передача. Сегодня переводим промпт из фразы в формат json и запускаем на
этом первую нашу небольшую серию. Итак, двигаться мы будем по уроку следующим образом. Сначала через
директивы мы соберем бренд направление. Это даст плотное стилистическое описание для полей style,
mood, lightning, в общем, всех тех полей, которые нам нужно при формировании json заполнить.
Потом открываем конструктор json промптов, который я для вас специально собрал. Туда подкладываем
готовый стилевой блок и обвешиваем пайлями под конкретный кадр. Потом запускаем серию из трех
кадров в Nano Banana Pro и сразу рядом тоже самое фразой, чтобы увидеть разницу в контролируемости. И
после чего пойдем в Nano Banana Pro и посмотрим, как все это работает. Загенерируем несколько изображений.
Подписка Google у тебя уже скорее всего есть, поэтому тут платить ни за что не придется. К концу урока у нас
будет на руках джейсон, который мы сможем переиспользовать под любой ассет нашего продукта. Это уже классный результат.
Но сразу отмечу, в отличие от остальных модулей курса, здесь сложно идти строго по пайплайну. Есть много инструментов, много всего, что нужно захватить везде. Есть небольшие отличия. И поэтому этот модуль у нас не столько строгий пайплайн, как это было до этого, а скорее набор знаний, которые в дальнейшем уже в рамках курсового проекта ты сможешь использовать.
Итак, смотри, вот так выглядит джейсон-билдер и так выглядит классический джейсон-промт. Давай разберемся, из чего он состоит.
Джейсон-промт дробит всю информацию на отдельные категории. Перечисляется все таким образом: сцена, описание сцены, объект, описание объекта и так далее.
Это позволяет строго структурировать весь твой промт и менять отдельные его куски, делать это быстро и удобно.
Итак, смотри, по умолчанию здесь уже добавлено несколько блоков промт: сцена, объект, освещение, камера и так далее.
Здесь можем добавлять бесконечное количество новых блоков, обзывать их как угодно, ну очень важно, чтобы это соответствовало тому, что ты хочешь конкретно внести в этот промт и перемещать их этапность.
Мы уже знаем, что зачастую для практически всех моделей приоритетность отдается тому, что в самом начале.
С разными моделями по-разному это работает, где-то это более явно выражается, где-то нет, но все-таки мы это держим в голове и самое основное всегда ставим в начало, просто про это не забываем.
Дальше, что еще здесь есть? Тут у нас есть такая кнопка, как шпаргалка, давай посмотрим, что в ней.
Нажимаем и здесь у нас справочник параметров: стиль, освещение, камера, объектив - это основные параметры, которые больше всего влияют на стилистику изображения.
Здесь есть ряд уже готовых стилей освещения камеры, можешь попробовать их самостоятельно, я сюда периодически их добавляю.
Эдиториал сприт, нажимаем, скопировано, все, это у нас стиль, в стиль мы можем это вставить.
Что-то у меня тут пропал стиль, давай сюда добавим style, вставили, все, эдиториал сприт.
И это такая небольшая шпаргалка, которая позволяет тебе посмотреть, какие есть варианты, как обычно это сформулировано.
Итак, с этим закончили, после чего, когда ты собрал свой промпт именно в JSON формате,
нажимаешь копировать и перекидываешь уже его в генератор изображений.
Это мы посмотрели нормальный, обычный режим, есть еще режим II.
Здесь он сам тебе генерирует набор этих свойств, блоков, сам промпт и так далее.
Но тут не так все просто, это мы посмотрим в конце.
Итак, под эти основные поля я собрал для тебя специально директиву.
Уже сейчас хотелось бы что-то погенерировать, посмотреть, собрать какой-то визуал.
Вот с этого мы и начнем.
В дальнейшем, если ты захочешь стилистически что-то поменять, переиграть, возможно, в каком-то там более крутом генераторе,
как, например, у Миджорни, ты найдешь свой идеальный стиль бренда, ты свободен это делать вообще в любой момент, действовать на свой вкус и цвет.
Итак, директиву я сюда уже закинул, как обычно мы все это делаем, перекидываем сюда и сразу запускаем вообще без объяснения того, что происходит.
Итак, после того, как выполнилась эта директива, он прочитал, чем мы занимаемся, кто мы такие, какие уже сейчас есть цвета в нашей палитре.
Он нам проводит бриф, что конкретно мы хотим выбрать, как мы видим нашу стилистику и так далее.
Здесь, в целом, если у тебя есть представление, если у тебя есть какое-то уже изображение референс, можешь закинуть сюда, он его адаптирует.
Я же не хочу сейчас все это делать, поэтому просто попрошу его собрать на свое усмотрение.
Выбери сам, как считаешь, лучше для моего бренда, для моего продукта.
Какой-то, на самом деле, очень модный якорь метафора, кассовый чек после трех часов в терминале, плюс мэйд, чейзис, макс, студио, индустриальный, не стартап.
Короче, здесь он прям навыдумывал, я постарался в него побольше стиля заложить в эту директиву, чтобы он действительно что-то интересное, необычное генерил.
Тут, как бы, имейте в виду, что в любом случае агент может немножко галлюцинировать, добавлять немного какого-то неона и прочего,
а когда ты используешь, в принципе, слово "неон" при генерации изображений, то почти всегда модели делают его максимально колхозным.
Поэтому перечитываем наш промпт, что там у нас получилось, и двигаемся с этим дальше.
Смотри, здесь он создал нам Brand Direction MD, и тут сразу JSON Prompt ready to use у нас готов.
Стиль, настроение, освещение, камера. Супер!
Теперь, что делаем дальше? Берем все это, либо добавляем сюда еще один блок, либо копируем это все и переносим к себе в JSON Builder.
Что у нас здесь? Если мы посмотрим на наш файлик, у нас тут стиль, настроение, освещение, камера.
Поэтому ровно такие же блоки нам нужны.
Теперь у нас будет стиль, вставляем, чтобы удобнее было работать.
Если что, можно здесь это поле растянуть, увеличить его здесь за уголок потянув.
Дальше у нас mood, настроение, тоже скопируем. У нас будет mood, здесь ничего растягивать не надо.
Дальше освещение, скопируем. Здесь у нас уже есть этот блок, также его чуть-чуть растянем для удобства.
И последний - это камера, какие-то дополнительные настройки.
Камера, если фото одно, второе, третье, здесь у нас в качестве примера оформлен этот блок.
Вообще, можно и на английском, конечно, все это делать, но здесь пока нам достаточно этого.
Промпт наш собран, то есть вот эта вся наша стилистика здесь в JSON-промпте определена.
Теперь можем добавлять новый блок, и он у меня будет называться object.
Называем object, и теперь мы можем просто менять это поле object, менять объекты и генерировать в том же стиле.
Ну, давай сделаем, например, hero-иллюстрация для сопроводительного лендинга к продукту.
Такое достаточно размытое описание, оставляем его и копируем этот промпт.
Теперь мы можем переходить в Gemini.
Обязательно не забываем выбирать наш оплаченный аккаунт и можем начинать генерировать изображение.
Тут нажимаем на плюсик, сразу берем создание изображений и закидываем наш JSON-промпт, пускай он генерирует.
Также на всякий случай можно дописать, что мы хотим использовать модель Nano Banana 2.
По умолчанию он должен выбирать ее, но не всегда это делает.
Иногда берет Nano Banana Pro, поэтому лучше просто скажем, почему Nano Banana 2, потому что она креативнее и быстрее работает.
Итак, такое изображение он создал, сделал сразу с небольшой версткой, с какими-то элементами, потому что я попросил hero-блок.
Выглядит интересно, сразу здесь какой-то футуристичный объект.
Это, по-моему, банан он сделал, техно-банан.
Да, Nano Banana 2 он добавил, потому что у меня это было в промпте.
Кстати, чтобы посмотреть, какая модель была использована для генерации, можем, а мы уже не можем.
Раньше это можно было, да.
Но, в любом случае, если один раз он уже сделал Nano Banana 2, последующих генераций он будет делать в ней же.
Поэтому один раз, возможно, будет такой косяк, но это не критично.
Понял, такой интересный стиль освещения.
В целом, блин, уже выглядит классно, выглядит интересно.
Давай попробуем создать новый чат, который не будет обладать контекстом предыдущего, не будет знать, что у нас уже было загенерировано, как оно выглядит.
То есть, по сути, делает то же самое с нуля.
И посмотрим, насколько стилистика этого визуала будет совпадать.
Опять же, у нас технический объект, текстура бумаги, шрифт, цвет.
Это все исходя из промпта он тут добавил.
Выглядит классно, выглядит похоже на то, что было до этого.
И таким образом мы можем что угодно генерировать.
Например, здесь давай сделаем объект, что-нибудь поинтереснее.
Например, какая-то цифровая станция, в которую заходит оплата криптой.
На ней QR-код расположен.
А из нее выходит уже цифровая сеть.
Как бы доступ к интернету, облачные сервера и так далее.
Тоже опять такой достаточно размытый промпт.
Копируем его и попробуем сгенерировать.
Также создам новый чатик, чтобы все было по-честному.
Чтобы он не видел контекст того, что у него до этого получилось.
И снова выбираем режим создания изображений.
Отправляем и немного ждем.
Итак, я попробовал запустить несколько раз.
Вот один из вариантов.
Выглядит классно.
Смотри.
И здесь особенно читается воспроизводимость нашей сцены.
У нас один и тот же угол освещения.
Одна и та же цветовая палитра.
Одна и та же идея вот этой контрастной типографики на фоне.
Опять же, текстура бумаги.
В целом, палитра всего.
Это все соответствует моему продукту.
Если я сейчас посмотрю другие варианты, то здесь тоже.
Опять же, мы видим вот этот угол наклона.
Одна и та же точка освещения.
Тень.
Текстура бумаги.
Контрастная типографика.
Палитра цветов.
Двигаемся дальше.
Открываем третий вариант.
Здесь уже визуал чуть попроще получился.
Но, тем не менее, опять же, все это читаемо.
Все это можно уже встраивать в продукт.
Ну, создавать таким образом серию снимков.
И она будет выглядеть консистентно.
Но, чего мы не учли.
Каждая модель думает по-своему.
С каждой моделью лучше по-своему взаимодействовать.
Есть и ограничения по количеству символов, которые она может съесть.
По тому, как она вообще с промптом работает.
По тому, как она воспринимает русский, английский язык.
Различные параметры и так далее.
И здесь нам поможет AI-режим в конструкторе джейсон промпта.
Смотри.
Открываем AI-мод.
И что здесь у нас есть?
Тут все работает через OpenRouter.
Это сервис, который предоставляет бесплатные API-ключи.
Мы уже говорили, что мы как дизайнеры API-ключами вообще не пользуемся.
Потому что это дорого.
Это бессмысленно переплачивать, если все это доступно в агрегаторах или в отдельных сервисах.
Но, почему бы этим не воспользоваться, если это совершенно бесплатно.
Поэтому, смотри, что мы делаем.
Нажимаем "Получить токен" и тебя перебрасывает автоматически на OpenRouter.AI.
Здесь тебе в первую очередь нужно зарегистрироваться, чтобы создавать свои новые API.
Итак, смотри.
Здесь есть куча разных моделей для генерации изображений, генерации текста и так далее.
Есть бесплатные, есть платные.
В чем тут особенность этого сервиса?
Здесь размещаются провайдеры вот этих как раз таки нейронок.
То есть, здесь у нас там Клод, который принадлежит Антропик.
Антропик заходит на этот сервис и предоставляет доступ к своей модели.
Соответственно, они тоже вряд ли горят желанием бесплатно раздавать свою модель.
Они делают это зачем-то.
Зачем здесь провайдеры это делают?
Они размещают здесь свои новые модели.
Они размещают здесь свои модели для того, чтобы их обучать и так далее.
И вот это, как правило, происходит в течение какого-то ограниченного времени.
Поэтому, имей в виду, если ты нашел какую-то бесплатную модель,
она здесь завтра у тебя уже может исчезнуть и нужно будет взять другую.
Итак, модели.
У нас есть модели для генерации текста, для генерации изображений и так далее.
Нам здесь все это не нужно.
Мы генерируем текст, мы генерируем конкретный промпт.
Поэтому переходим в текстовые модели и ищем здесь бесплатные.
Промпт прайсинг ставим на free и смотрим, какие модели у нас здесь есть.
Здесь есть описание этих моделей.
Модели разные, подходят под разные задачи.
Просто читай описание этих моделей.
Можно было бы сказать, что бери вот байду, но завтра здесь не будет этой байды.
И тебе нужно научиться самому ориентироваться по этому сайту.
Поэтому читаем описание, смотрим, для чего это лучше подходит.
Та или иная модель.
И выбираем из них.
Вот, например, первая из них, вот эта самая байду, она ориентирована именно на программирование.
Задача у нас не сложная, сформировать промпт.
Но можно поискать еще что-нибудь более подходящее.
Следующая модель All Alpha.
All Alpha is High Performance.
Короче, крутая модель для агентских workflow.
Что такое агентский workflow?
Это выполнение различных задач.
Соответственно, эта модель не запрограммирована на один какой-то пул задач, а на разные.
И для выполнения смежной работы, генерации промпта, мне кажется, она лучше подойдет.
Поэтому переходим к этой модели.
И что нам здесь нужно?
Во-первых, я надеюсь, к этому моменту ты уже зарегистрировался.
Первое, мы копируем название этой модели.
Возвращаемся сюда и здесь выбираем эту модель.
Берем другая модель.
Здесь у нас в списке ее не будет.
Вставляем.
Все, можем двигаться дальше.
Теперь нам еще нужен ключ.
Для этого здесь переходим в API.
Нажимаем создать API ключ.
И, ну, как-нибудь его рандомно называем.
Здесь нажимаем new key и как-нибудь его называем.
Ну, например, я назову его all lesson.
Никаких лимитов, expiration.
Здесь ничего не нужно.
Нажимаем создать и копируем этот ключ.
Обрати внимание, если ты один раз этот ключ скопировал, больше у тебя возможности сделать это не будет.
Поэтому сохраняем его, либо потом придется пересоздавать новый ключ.
Сохранили ключ, вернули сюда, вставили этот самый ключ.
Теперь двигаемся дальше.
Под какую нейросеть мы пишем?
У меня nanobanan2.
Просто по тегу ее можно выбрать.
Язык ввода.
Вывода.
Давай сделаем английским.
Пускай будет так.
И здесь можно описать, что мы хотим сгенерировать.
Я возьму вот это какая-то цифровая станция, в которую заходит оплата криптой.
И сюда также можно стилистическое наше описание закинуть.
Можно, кстати, даже стиль освещения и все это сюда закинуть.
Просто, чтобы оно автоматически применилось.
Добавлю это в конец.
Сначала описание объекта, потом все остальное.
Здесь, конечно, идея в том, что ты не будешь сразу готовый json prompt использовать.
Там какую-то стилистику в него закидывать.
Возможно, кратко ее опишешь, а он уже за тебя доразовьет, как это должно выглядеть.
Итак, ограничения по символам также здесь можно поставить.
Это зависит от того, где ты работаешь, где-то это ограничение есть, где-то нет.
Тут уже на твое усмотрение.
В целом, вот 2500 - это прям золотая середина.
То есть, при работе с Nanobanan 2 она может там и 5000 символов съесть.
Но ты должен понимать, что чем больше объем этого текста, тем меньше она от него возьмет.
Если этот текст будет покороче, то он возьмет все из него.
Если очень длинный, то он сфокусируется на начале, а на остальное просто может забить.
Поэтому 2500 - это прям вот такая верхняя планка.
Оставим это значение и нажмем "Сгенерировать структуру".
Все, прошло немного времени, он успешно все это дело сгенерировал.
Итак, здесь он по умолчанию сам создает style, mood, такие важные поля.
Я сюда закидывал этот стиль из нашего JSON-промта просто для того, чтобы они тут были,
чтобы он не придумывал из головы, а постарался приблизиться к тому, что у нас уже есть.
Здесь ты можешь просто описывать, что ты хочешь генерировать.
Он всю структуру тебе соберет, там подробное описание всего этого.
А в остальные поля уже из своего JSON-промта, из агента,
можешь сюда закинуть этот текст.
Ну просто имей в виду, что тут он еще ограничивает это на 2500 символов.
Короче, можно делать и так, и так.
Итак, промт наш готов.
В целом, я здесь даже ничего не буду править.
Есть у нас сцена, описание самого объекта, стиль, настроение, свет, камера, ну в общем, вся база.
Копируем, возвращаемся в Gemini, закидываем ему и смотрим, что у нас получится.
Я, кстати, в этот раз не ставил, что нужно генерировать изображение.
Он сам понял, что нужно сделать, потому что формат ввода такой, что это JSON-промт с описанием сцены и прочего.
Он догадался сам, что нужно генерировать изображение.
Итак, сгенерировал изображение.
Ну, на самом деле, уже поинтереснее получилось, более такое драматичное освещение.
Вот эти все линии и так далее.
Можно попробовать, я думаю, еще посмотреть, что получится второй раз.
Второй он тоже сгенерировал.
Здесь, да, есть небольшой артефакт, это можно поправить.
Но мне нравится, что тут это прям уже какой-то жесткий хай-тек.
От того, что у нас там бумага на фоне и прочее, мы отступили немного, но получился более интересный результат, более креативный.
Он попросил его убрать лишний текст, увеличить разрешение изображения, как видишь, оно достаточно высокое, и закинул в Hero в качестве фонового изображения.
По-моему, выглядит классно.
Итак, к чему мы пришли?
Чтобы у тебя получалось воспроизводимо, классно, круто, очень похоже, ты можешь использовать тот JSON-промт, который отдает тебе агент по директиве.
Она, как обычно, будет под уроком.
Но, имея в виду, что там слишком уж все будет похоже.
Если ты хочешь более универсальный промт, можешь воспользоваться JSON-билдером, именно его AI-фичой.
Там он уже креативит, создает новые промты, исходя из твоих вводных, и там тебе остается только object менять и генерировать в этой стилистике новые и новые объекты.
То есть, именно в этой стилистике, но, возможно, композиционно немного иные.
Так или иначе, JSON позволяет нам очень четко контролировать, ограничивать модели в их креативности и легко заменять отдельные куски нашего промта, чтобы что-то улучшить, изменить или сгенерировать просто новый пак ассетов.
В качестве домашней работы тебе нужно также создать свой JSON-промт для бренда и сгенерировать в NanoBanano с тремя разными объектами изображения в этой твоей стилистике.
Эти три изображения в Zen-классе при сдаче домашнего задания прикрепляешь, и на этом все, с этим будет удобно работать.
На этом все, увидимся в следующем уроке. До встречи!